and once in the 80s then in 1994 a bunch
of infected monkeys got out because
Tulane University had their primate
testing facility Center in our town and
a bunch of infected monkeys got out and
they let us out of YMCA summer camp
tough the police looked for him bro I
remember they came to summer camp and it
basically took the kids to look for let
me get that pen real quick not kids
they're the tallest boys
they took the tallest boys right out and
uh and we helped them look for them I
remember surrounding a couple of chimps
outside of a Kenny Rogers Roasters dude
off of Highway 190.
that's a true story dude that's the name
of your book huh oh we surrounded some
chips up next to a Kenny Rogers Roasters
and dude this [__] got racial like
people go around town they're really
young I mean this is [__] up I mean
this just shows you how far in the South
you are people like 90 monkeys just
escaped from this place or whatever and
you literally have like you know people
riding around with guns [__]
Confederate flags it's like dude these
are animals man like relax like the [__]
almost got it was weird you know I knew
dude I mean you know I grew up around
some [__] real crazy poor white
people you know the dude no on if they
had a dude in our town no arms used to
[__] fight everybody you know that
dude you know what I'm saying he'd get
you in that Lurch he would catch you
with this between his chin and his chest
even [__] snack you like a snake we
were talking about this dude with the
ass boy Gert was his name and he would
just get you like that bruh and he'd
choke you down he had no arms no arms at
all any fight anybody dude and he would
choke you he would show if you went to
punch him how would he block oh bro he
spent out of it he'd spin he'd ducky
Dodge the dude had I mean he just would
he catch your hand with his neck huh
would he catch you oh he would just
Lurch at you and bro the thing is here
was that oh you know what if he hits you
with that shoulder you're going down
yeah part of it the big move was that
choke he would get he would catch you
like this where would he catch you your
hand
he would catch you neck to neck
that's [__] crazy once he got you
neck to neck hurt you but this whole
family the whole family was [__] he
could choke you out psychos bro brother
it's sharpened half of his teeth on one
side of his mouth dude these people
would [__] you up one of the kids was in
a wheelchair just they never taught him
to walk I think I don't even think he
was crippled they just never taught him
to walk and so the other brother would
carry him on his back everywhere like a
backpack dude and didn't even give a
[__] one time we go get like takovaki
used to be the kind of vodka that we
would drink it was just like this off
brand in our region like Todd's almost
uh yeah probably like something like
that just like whatever everybody's had
their own little local brand or whatever
and this this was called taka and so you
go get a fifth attack or whatever so one
time I'll pull up by the
um gas station and they had this man and
I was thinking oh this guy will buy some
vodka he looks like he drinks some vodka
and it was daytime you know it's
probably maybe 11 A.M so uh I pick it I
say hey man will you get some liquor he
say yeah I said all right here's the
money
you got to go in and get the liquor come
back out and get in the car it was kind
of do you get to give exact directions
to yeah you know otherwise you can
deviate from the plan I buy like some
[__] uh Slim Jims scratches yeah
scratches [__] the dice yeah
um so anyway he gets back in the car
he's got the liquor and that's when this
dude told me he's like you know I'm the
head button champion in the world right
last thing you want to hear from I'm
talking this guy the only man I've ever
seen you you had that thick head oh this
guy's head was probably made by that
Shoemaker right he had that kind of head
he had to shoot you're smaller than
Chin's head Chin's has a dome on him it
was like Chin's head with another chin
head on top of it all forehead oh yeah
yeah it was that jaundice snowman it was
like stacking up a couple of Chin's
heads right this guy had just like you
could see his you could hear his neck if
you put your ear up to his neck he could
his neck would be like man I'm tired you
know oh that's awesome
and you would said button people no he
goes I'm driving us off he has the vodka
and all my I want the vodka from him
right I'm trying to get [__] up and he
goes you know I'm the head button
champion of the world right and this
dude's homeless Okay so
until you say I didn't know there was a
competition answer and this before they
had it this way before this is 20 years
before Kimbo Slice right and this man
looked exactly like Kimbo Slice right
but white with a two-story hit oh he's
black but white or black but black all
right 100 black and he so next thing you
know he goes you know I'm the head
button champion of the world
and you start to see him kind of just
looking at me as I just feel like
suddenly you sizing up your Dome yeah
suddenly I'm looking forward driving and
he's looking directly at me right there
is no us we're not going anywhere
anymore he is just in the car with me
and uh and so I pull and he goes do you
want he goes do you think you could beat
me and I knew but when he said do you
think anything at that point I'm already
thinking of the cops I'm thinking about
funeral I'm thinking of dude in the back
get in there I'm thinking about yeah I'm
[__] up but you can't just get out of
a car when you're driving and that's one
of the issues with cars is that you have
some responsibility to stay in there at
least it's yours
so I still I pull over because I'm not
going to get knocked unconscious while
I'm moving forward you know what I'm
saying about a [__] idiot yeah so
this dude he goes you want to know and I
know he couldn't even hear me anymore
though I'm saying no he's seeing red oh
yeah for him it's game time yeah
I'm saying no in different ways I'm
saying no in different languages and you
can tell it's not registered in his head
and he just lines me up right and just
hit me as hard as he could with this
[__] head bro yeah not me completely
unconscious only been knocked out twice
in my life once was actually about three
weeks ago when I fell into the sofa when
I was wrestling with some children the
other time was when this dude the
self-proclaimed headbutton champion of
the world
if I can put that one hit sleeper on me
bro here's the crazy part he didn't even
touched me with his hands
did he leave the Vodka at least
everything was gone dude everything was
gone yeah that's the champ though that's
the chance how many people can say he
got knocked out by the chair it's a kind
of an honor man yeah and my first
thought was that dude is the champ
that's my first thought that's the champ
right there no doubt that message yeah
where do you get all those hamsters from
that's well they breed them in our town
I used to work for this group they used
to sell tattooed hamsters and guinea
pigs after uh they tattoo them yeah they
used to Brand them with concerts and
Rays they would say it's tattooed just
to make people not be as sad about it
for what like what did it say uh 311
Green Day anything like a different
bands that were coming to town Toadies
I swear to God bruh toady's Acid Bath we
used to truck these hats into the City
and [__] Venom bruh because there
wasn't much there wasn't much work in
our town dude you know you had to get
what you could get and they had a man
that bred hamsters and then they had to
do the tattoos and they [__] met up
and that was a merger that's big
business you know and they started uh
[Laughter]
dude they have one kid in our in our in
our neighborhood Who uh
uh his dad was a Elvis impersonator
right but in a small town like you don't
work much you know what I'm saying like
if they only have 1100 people in town
nobody needs a [__] Elvis
impersonators yeah for what and he was
really just a drunk you know and he was
hiding behind the costume
but around Christmas they'd let him
dress up like Santa the city would pay
him and he was a seasonal greeter he
would [__] greet people by the way
they were like all right he could pull
Elvis off I'm sure
so but uh and he [__] I remember he
made his son a wooden shirt one time
what
what for Christmas
he made this boy Nathan bro he made
little Nathan a [__] wooden shirt
because I remember holding half of it up
when they [__] nailed him into it
instead of they had to nail him into the
shirt he has a plywood shirt couldn't
slide it over and I'll be honest with
you dude we [__] and he loved it he
was like the only thing his dad ever
made and probably or got him I remember
he was [__] crying and [__] tears
on top of the [__] plywood yes ply
but it was wood and it was sanded uh uh
it was rough
I swear to God but he kept it outside or
something yeah
that's what I remember anyway I'm trying
to think of what else I could have it
could have been a you know rats but I
think it was Hornets but uh and we
didn't draw swastikas on it because we
were anti-doo we didn't we didn't know
any Jews we just seen like drawings and
[__] at school and pamphlets and [__]
you know yeah I believe you but uh but
anyway oh we locked a fit we locked this
stuff this big girl in our town we like
this big girl one time we eat some acid
and we locked this big girl into a room
at this party and uh and we kept going
in there with [__] pots of [__]
warm water [__] pouring it on I feel
bad I feel horrible dude I didn't look
we was kids and we were on ass and dude
and then bro you can't tell me this
though when I'm straight you gotta tell
me how mushrooms you blocked the girl I
just remember how old were you I just
remembered probably 16.
I know but here's the thing let's say I
was 14 that way it makes it sound nice
but look she's
bruh
I was dude and what happened was and we
kept going in the room with like these
pots of warm I don't know why we had the
pots of warm water because I think they
just were [__] up dude
but not like Torchy's well she wasn't in
a cage enough she was just you know free
range in this room right I think she was
scared to come out and then one time we
went in bro we heard this loud sound and
we went in and she she had ran against
one of the walls so hard but had [__]
moved the entire wall in this house dude
huge girl about two 240 pounds beautiful
girl too the most beautiful biggest girl
that I've ever known
uh beautiful girl beautiful hair
beautiful face large just large and
beautiful but she [__] got lifted bro
and I always like making people laugh
like I used to do a similar thing when I
was a child at the lunch table we'd get
some kids who were minerals or a couple
of them might have been mentals and a
couple kids that were well you know and
we get there and sit them to make them
drink milk and then tell jokes and do
stuff and until one of them just blew
milk out of their face you know
and if you get some straight up just
couple minerals boy some straight up saw
it off humans you get them to do you get
them to straight up blow leche out there
haha
that's America right there
you know what I'm saying and that's when
I knew I was like oh I got some kind of
a gift here you know almost blew the
throat out of this this one boy named
tot t-o-t with his name
kind of a bad name too to be mentally
challenged
but also easy for him to spell and
I'm not joking that's what his father
said and
um easy for him to smell backward and
forward same name Todd
dude I was in Louisville one time I came
out of a show they had a big group in
the limousine they invited me to go to
an after party with them right I was
like I'm only coming if my boy can come
and like who's your boy and I'm like La
Cedric they had a brother nearby right
wearing this Louis Vuitton jacket dude
probably about 60 homeless right and
they're like that's your boy and I
didn't even talked to this dude right I
was like yeah that's my boy like all
right he can come so I [__] walk over
him looking right in the eyes and I was
like what's up man I'm Theo he's like
Cedric and uh I was like all right dude
I told these people you're my friend you
ever been in a limousine he's like nah I
was like all right come get him with us
just act like you're my friend right
we're going to a party he's like all
right man so we go in the limo bro we're
in there hot chicks dudes people [__]
little Cedric kept saying we're friends
that's what he kept saying out loud
right kind of [__] not the best actor
bro what did we get to this house party
it's a nice cool [__] party bro I'm
downstairs I'm in the kitchen somebody's
making us a drink I'm talking to
somebody
[__] is six minutes later right here
[__] somebody scream I hear a window
break right
it comes running down they said some
dude just stole like four verses
out of the coat room upstairs
and [__] jumped out of window
that would have been me Doug and that
was [__] listen bro
uh and that was like but and everybody
there was like crying and pissed
and some girl was like Furious because
all her tampons were in there or
something I remember she got pissed she
was a tough girl she was like one of
those uh what are those people that
slide the thing on the ice she said
curlers because she was a curler
but I was in my head I was like this is
the best [__] night ever
oh